we're here at CES unveil getting a
preview of some of the cool stuff we're
going to see at the show later this week
one of the things I've really liked
these goggles from liquid image they're
called extreme sports goggles and
they've got integrated HD cameras built
in between the eyes here so you don't
have to mount your POV cameras on your
helmet looked like an idiot you can see
we've got the lens right here between
the eyes it shoots 1080p video the drive
is right here records on a micro SD
drive up to about 30 minutes of video
and if you're doing really high speed
stuff which I try to avoid you can shoot
at 7 20 is 60 frames a second so you can
get all the action in there they make
them for snow sports cycling scuba even
swimming which I think would be kind of
boring to see through point of view
camera but it's there if you wanted they
retail for four hundred dollars and
they're available in February